foreign
[Music]
we're back StarTalk sports edition we're
talking about the Olympics a series of
these programs where we're just trying
to figure out what's going on how does
it work
and all the ways that science might be
informing it so so Gary who do you have
for this segment
um we have the most wonderfully
interesting athlete paralympian Matt
stutzman uh Juan Silva in the London
Olympics in 2012.
um Guinness World Record holder for the
most accurate arrow shot at a Target
over Distance by any individual
310 yards that's three football fields
all in a line and then some right now
team gold in the parapan Olympic Games
and an individual silver in the para
paralympic games Matt welcome welcome to
start talk dude uh thanks for having me
okay so if I'm going on a hunting trip
I'm taking you
I'm down I'm down do you ever hunt do
you do you go bear hunting with the bow
uh you know what I have it I haven't
bear hunted yet because I feel like
um if I don't do good he will chase me
down and try to get my arms off or
something like that I can't afford to
lose any more appendages yeah no more
limbs limbs for you let me could you
just explain
um how forgive my naivete here but how
do the Paralympics work I presume each
sport has its own rules about what needs
to be your circumstances in order to
participate so uh in the case of the
Paralympics archery
how what are the rules about that
uh so the division that I'm in
um is basically they're looking at uh
the least amount of disability possible
so pretty much everybody in my group of
let's say a hundred all of them have
most of their disabilities are from the
waist down whether they're paralyzed and
have to be in a wheelchair or they lost
a leg and they have to stand on a
prosthetic there's different categories
but that's the most competitive category
and that's where I want to be because I
just want to be the best yeah well I
mean really you're just showing off
that's what he's doing that's what he's
doing this let's be honest I mean
there's a guy who's just like yeah I
have a prosthetic leg and you know I can
hit a target from 100 yards and you're
like uh bro I don't have arms I don't
have arms and I hit a Target and I can
do that from three and I can do it from
three times the distance
he wins every argument there ever was
there is no argument to have man I can't
hands down you know
let's roll back a little bit here
um this Guinness Book of Records which
you own outright
um someone was saying to me that when
you attempted this because of the
Crosswinds you had to aim at an air
conditioning unit on a building in a
completely different place to hit the
target what is going in the air so that
so that the air would move it onto the
Target and you have to know that in
advance yeah is that what happened there
yeah so so the real estate you have to
use a 60 pound bow and you only get
three attempts you know ever to make it
yet wait for the non-archers when you
say 60 pounds that's the force necessary
to pull the strap to draw back not that
the bow weighs 60 pounds just to be
clear correct okay good correct that is
the the kinetic energy that pushes the
arrow forward is 60 pounds yeah if it
weighs 60 pounds you'd be Hercules
but I would definitely need bigger arm
muscles for that one but yeah so yeah so
to figure out how to shoot that far away
when you do the math you have to aim at
a certain angle uh you know like whether
it's like 32 degrees or whatever that is
and you have to calculate the arrow
speed and you and so for me it just so
happened that where I needed to aim to
calculate all this to actually hit the
bullseye
I aimed at an air conditioning unit
across the street at like a high-rise
building it it happened to be like right
in the perfect place so I was aiming at
that in all my calculations that's where
it ended up being so you're not only a
ex expert Bowman you're a sniper too
intuitive scientists it was calculating
mentally that's the that is the that's
the Hallmark of a great sniper able to
adjust for uh Crosswinds and and
distance
we need a poster with Matt with the with
the target hit and and the caption just
says do the math
I just thought you'd ask the simple
question how many times did you hit the
air conditioning unit
that's a chuck chuck you should have
used that with you Chuck that was you
you dropped that one truck I did I did
so how many times did you hit the air
conditioning
he killed three people in that apartment
building
so real quick they never actually found
out it was me because I don't leave
fingerprints to prove it
yeah I told you it was a snack
no wait wait so Matt let me ask another
naive question and forgive me if this
sounds sort of ableist right so
um do you have an advantage
over those who would have lost their
arms later in life you having been born
with no arms so you only ever have known
life with no arms
absolutely there's an advantage uh it's
it's funny because when I first got in
archery they're like there's no way you
can shoot a bow you have no arms it's
impossible you have to use your arm to
shoot a bow well then I I started
shooting a bow and then they're like wow
wait and you aimed at them
here's how I can't shoot that's right
wow that would be a great argument
there's no way you can shoot a boat
damn I guess I was wrong
last words on his Tombstone I I guess I
was wrong
um yes but your brain has never known
arms so you're not fighting a
pre-expectation of what you can do yeah
so if they tested my brain and they said
that the average person's brain the area
of their brain that controls their feet
motor skills is the size of a pee and
mine's like the size of like a softball
to do all this extra stuff with my feet
you know I probably just said we don't
need hands let's just throw that chunk
of the brain out and we'll use that to
store footstep I guess for those only
hearing this uh we I can describe that
you're looks like you're sitting in some
kind of a garage workshop and there's
some badass looking vehicle over your
left shoulder but what what's going on
in that is that what is it is that a
safe house is that a bunker like where
are you you know something so what I'm
not shooting my bow I love cars and I
love working on cars I do almost all the
work myself and what's behind me right
here is my race car that I just got done
building and fixing up tell me about
some of your science background uh you
you sound you you sound sufficiently
physics fluent so that tells me you must
have had some Physics in your portfolio
not a lot a lot of it was just kind of
like self-taught growing up uh that
works too bad works too I I lived on a
farm and I had to a lot of times
think of how I was going to do it like
for example I remember I was like eight
years old and my dad said I needed to
carry this five gallon bucket of feed
out to the trough and I had to figure
out
how I was gonna take a board and put it
across from one feed bucket and then
stand up underneath it and balance and I
had to figure out like I was out there
with a measuring stick trying to find
the middle of the stick so when I lifted
up on it it wouldn't fall you know so
there was things like that throughout my
whole life that I had to rely on like
physics and math to just kind of
overcome things really so Matt you're a
father of three boys right so how do you
how do you do the super dad Hero at home
while you prepare to go to a Paralympics
in Tokyo and race a car yeah you know
what's amazing about my boys is just
like
they don't know anything different this
is who they know this is their dad they
go along with my craziness whether I'm
shooting my bow working on cars uh they
just support me in fact they are one of
the biggest motivations in my life on
why I push myself to where I'm at
because
without them pushing me
I mean that's honestly how I fell on
archery in the first place because I
nobody would hire me and I could and I
couldn't figure out how to get a job
because people would say you have no
arms and so they wouldn't hire me so I
found archery to put food on the table
for them
so if it wasn't for them I probably
wouldn't have done this I would have
been trying to figure out something else
so
wow man so when you shoot what what are
the mechanics behind you shooting yeah
yeah take us through what that is okay
so how about
um as I'm explaining it I can also show
you oh my gosh nice sweet what do you
like this yeah very sweet okay good
person okay and do it and because many
people will only hear this if you could
be a little more
descriptive descriptive thank you Chuck
all right you can be a little more
descriptive than you otherwise would be
Okay so
this right here is a release Aid that I
had made this is the only modification
that I use to shoot my bow so when you
look at a bow or when you're listening
or in your mind visualizing a bow I'm
shooting a normal bow that you would buy
off the shelf that you would use to
shoot with your hands so like they
didn't specifically make this bow for me
whatsoever
and that's and that's legit there's that
within the rules yep everything's within
the rule so and even even this thing
that's on my shoulder right here is
within the rules so it's a kind of a
yolk around your shoulders I put on a
strap that goes underneath my armpits
and across my chest and then I tighten
it up and over my right shoulder I have
a release Aid
that looks like a trigger of maybe like
a gun or something like that and it has
a Long Bar that bar goes on my chin so
when I'm aiming I pull with my shoulder
that applies pressure to that little
trigger which allows the bow to shoot
but is it your chin or your teeth that
that engage that uh it's my chin so I
put it in my mouth right to hook it onto
the bow and you hook it on to the bow
and then as you pull back with your
shoulder that causes the bow to come
back but then all you have to do is put
your chin down during the release and
then the hook pulls up and bang bang so
so this bow that I'm going to use right
now is above that I'm actually going to
use at the games
um and it is shooting a little itty
bitty
skinny arrow and I know you guys are
into this stuff but this this Arrow
weighs 400
and 29 grains
okay well it shoots out of my bow
at 200 miles per hour oh my God so
literally as I fire the boat when you
guys see this what by the time this
Arrow hits the target which is only
going to be about three or four feet
away from me it's already doing 200
miles per hour
um nice okay so it would be at 200 miles
an hour the instant it separates from
the string and so because that's the
last moment where it's getting any
energy that you supplied it yeah and
then the rest is just is aerodynamics
and gravity at that point okay so now
you're seated it does slow down over a
period of 310 yards but you have to
calculate That Into You know how much is
it going to slow down I know when I did
that shot it was about a six second
Arrow flight okay so you have to so you
have to shoot wherever that air
conditioner was it was surely High to
the side of the Target because of the
Crosswinds but also had to have been
above the Target because you have to
have it allowed the hour to drop yeah it
was about uh 20 I think it was like a 28
or 30. it might have been a 32 degree
angle that I was aiming
in the air so 32 degrees up that's like
like that gotcha wow okay so
I rest about for people who can't see uh
arrest the bow against my left leg and
I'm sitting in a a chair I use my right
foot to pick up the arrow and load it
onto the bow
like that
I then use my right leg and grab the bow
and I pick it up and I sit gentleman
style or I cross my legs so it kind of
brings my right foot up to my chest at
this point
I take my release date and I bend down
to the string and I hook it on
like that
and now that it's hooked on
I picked the bow up with my right foot
and uh so now it's very weird awkward
yoga position
okay so at this point I'm going to take
my right foot and push it away from my
chest
and now you're now you're getting that
60 pounds of force yeah so I don't know
if you guys can see all that but that's
what it looks like okay so then I aim at
the Target bring the trigger up to my
jaw you see okay yeah okay and then I
add pressure until it shoots
bam just like that look at that that
results in bullseyes and metals
and lots of smiles
you've got to do that you've got a set
number of arrows to release in a set
period of time
that's intense how are you controlling
how are you able to dial yourself down
and focus in the middle of competition
um so you shoot 72 errors for
qualification and you shoot six arrows
at a time and you get four minutes to
shoot each six Arrow group and then you
go score them pull them and stuff but
when I do that
I'm so in the zone that when I like when
I draw my bow back I don't know who's
around me you know I practice the timing
I do a lot of mental prep uh what a good
shot feels like so the distance that
will shoot in um Tokyo is 50 meters all
right and that's nothing for you damn
they're both sides they should just hand
you the metal and then you keep it hey
you know what I'll take that
uh the bullseye's is smaller than a CD
okay so a perfect a perfect score is 720
points and the world record is 705.
and uh the last several months or so
I've been shooting in practice about
708 to 712 range
of your ass oh my God I got it I got
this year has been amazing for me as far
as mentally I I just got back from
trials and beat the old world record by
12 points around over 20 points is what
the the new so I now own the new world
record so that's amazing that's two
World Records so just just send it a
comparison if you guys want to know so
um I average like 700 points at 50
meters okay
the number one ranked able-bodied Archer
um in the world shoots for United States
of America and on the same day on the
same field uh when they were shooting
their scores they shot a 7-0
4 maybe and I shot 700 so that I'm only
like three or four points off the number
one
able-bodied archer in the world so as a
comparison
right yeah well there is no comparison
you make him look like dog food
let's be real here so Matt when you when
you rock up do you all of a sudden get a
lot of attention
Because of Who You Are yeah yeah and do
the other athletes get a similar sort of
attention and does that kind of blow
them out but for you you seem to have
grown obviously into this attention and
is it is it you know what I've been here
before I'm not phased by this or um do
you see the other athletes getting kind
of outside of their comfort zone with
the attention oh for sure you know uh
what one thing that's interesting is
I've been my whole life used to
attention and what I mean by that is is
it could be negative attention too like
people making fun of me because I have
no arms or like I'm mad he's a kid yeah
yeah I'm like eating you in a restaurant
with my feet and everybody in the
restaurant's staring at me right so my
whole entire life I've been able to say
you know what I don't care what they
think I'm gonna do me none of that bugs
me like I don't care I'm gonna block
them out so when it comes to archery and
I get into that on the on the stage of
it means something and we have thousands
of people watching
I don't even know that they're there
whereas let's say for you let's say
let's say I'm shooting you know against
Gary or something he's never been in
that situation right yeah so you shot
really good and now you're shooting for
a gold medal but you've never shot in
front of 10 000 people before
so there is an advantage there for me
you know because I've been dealing with
my whole life and they haven't been
you'd make a great stand-up comic
I honestly you gotta you gotta have that
you gotta have that same mentality it's
like I don't care if these people not
laughing
the only Chuck has to feel that way
other Comics are actually laughing at me
so I'm delighted by how much physics you
picked up in your life and and as Gary
said a lot of it would come intuitively
to you if you didn't have the formal
training you were thinking about nature
and forces and energy the right way and
on this show we're delighted to learn
when athletes throw in some math to get
their medal and so Matt it's been a
pleasure to have you on this program we
will all be watching you in Tokyo and
yeah and good good luck but it doesn't
even sound like you need it
I'll take all the good luck I appreciate
you guys inviting me onto the show it's
been amazing I loved all the laughs
thank you again all right we got to end
it there Max Dutchman thanks for being
such a good sport on Star Talk we will
all be watching you on the Olympics and
Beyond Gary Chuck always good to have
you Neil deGrasse Tyson here as always
we keep looking up
[Music]